TBS offers Andy and I in Show waiter
service in show waiter surface yeah it's
insane we got these menus here we can
order anything we want off this TBS menu
we're gonna get something and they bring
yeah you want it sir
yeah yeah well peckish let's get our in
show waiter Craig out here yeah hey
we're doing great I get you an appetizer
or drink to start actually yeah you know
what I'd like to start with a Rob Roy if
you could use Oban
single malt scotch you want to write
this down maybe oh no I got it
okay okay a Rob Roy Oban scotch and
instead of draw or actually dry vermouth
instead of sweet vermouth and could you
just give me the bitters in a [ __ ] on
the side and also a couple of maraschino
cherries yeah and you you got all them
yeah I did yeah okay could you repeat it
back to me I can I totally can but I'd
rather just keep taking your orders okay
you don't need you wanna get something
yeah I'll just get a Pellegrino with
lime mm-hmm okay also I'll have a glass
of the Foxen toasted rope Syrah
okay how about any appetizers to start
uni should get a pen and write this down
no that's okay I got it you can keep
going okay all right I'll have the
radicchio salad with the wild arugula
manchego dates sherry vinaigrette could
you hold the marcona almonds sure yeah
yeah I would really appreciate if you
got a pen and just wrote our orders down
yeah it would actually make me feel a
lot better to write but there's no need
it's it's all up here
okay all right well fine Andy and I will
split the paia Delmar within black tiger
shrimp sea scallops calamari no mussels
please green peas red bell peppers
artichokes like Ellie and I Olli extra
parsley if you can if you don't mind can
you put the pimento oregano hoja banca
olive oil on the side yo peace
a sun-dried tomato focaccia maybe Oh
instead of the saffron rice can we sub
in the lime basmati yeah yeah sure thing
okay okay your don't want to write any
of that down no no a good waiter does
not have to write it down okay that's
the thing Craig what's that you're not a
good waiter okay you've you've never
been a good waiter you've come out here
several times before assuring us you
don't need to write anything down as we
give you incredibly long involved orders
then you go backstage you forget
everything and you kill yourself it's
happened every single time has it has
what yes look at the tape
it's incredible last time you took our
orders then you left for the kitchen
backstage you forgot it all so you put
on a wig then change into a sweat suit
then you jumped off a mountain
another time you forgot so you changed
into a purple leotard then you put on a
trap piece and you fell to your death
and it always ends up being an adverb it
ends up being the same ad for big banks
over and over and over again yeah I I
think that was just a some kind of a
mix-up in the kitchen mix that's your
answer it's a mix-up that's why you put
on costumes run backstage and kill
yourself is a mix-up just why are you
why are you putting on a Green Bay
Packers sweatshirt your your my last
table of the night so I'm just kind of
getting cozy I'm gonna get your order
and then I'll be right back out I don't
know why right-ho oh he'll be right home
what's he doing
hey everybody it's our in-house thugs
rusty and Omar what's up guys boss want
us to make sure that way to get your
orders you know what that's a good idea
thanks guys make sure he gets the or
that yeah go get our food blank you've
gotta get their food Oh big pins maybe
you should write it down
[Music]
still hungry
longest setup to a sketch in the history
of the world wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]